[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
francesas de nuevo el duelo entre
mccrone y le pain que decide decidirá el
futuro de este país y también el de
europa nos acompañan en este estudio
víctor hugo ramírez politólogo y doctor
en demografía por la sorbona bienvenido
víctor hola que tal silvia yus o
corresponsal del país en francia
bienvenida selva y jan fredixon es
historiador y docente en la escuela de
altos estudios en ciencias sociales
bienvenido hola qué tal la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
aquí en francia el duelo lepén macrón
hoy en primera plana
[Música]
son los mismos candidatos pero cinco
años después y el contexto es
completamente diferente el presidente
macro ni la ultraderechista lepén se
enfrenta en el 24 de abril en la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones tal y como pasó
en 2017 esta vez el duelo parece mucho
más ajustado por varias razones el
presidente ya no cuenta con el efecto
novedad y lepén ha continuado con este
proceso desde abolición y ha centrado su
campaña en hablar a los franceses de su
primera preocupación en estos momentos
el poder adquisitivo con la inflación y
la subida de los precios por la crisis
energética ante los temores que
despierta el ep en la mayoría de los
otros candidatos que quedaron eliminados
en primera vuelta llaman al frente
republicano que tantas veces ha
funcionado en este país el problema es
que ahora ese fondo es raquítico a nivel
de peso electoral y son los votantes del
tercero dischord discordia los del
izquierdista melanson quienes se
transforman en árbitro de este partido
repasemos algunas portadas revista el
este es un duelo de francia contra
francia dos modelos distintos el diario
le monde se apoya en la cartografía del
voto de francia para explicar que este
segundo duelo es más incierto la tribu
titula el 24 de abril
se producirá el falso remake del 17
empecemos por ahí precisamente por ese
paralelismo por lo que pasó hace 5 años
son las mismas personas macro ni lepén
pero no son los mismos personajes que
semejanzas y diferencias víctor ven
entre este duelo del 22 con el que se
produjo hace 5 años a ver tú lo has
dicho muy bien es un remake con
diferencias y con similitudes qué
similitudes tenemos bueno que en 2010
tanto 2017 como 2022 son elecciones que
muestran la recomposición política de
francia del del panorama francés del
panorama político tenemos elecciones que
han sepultado a los dos partidos
políticos tradicionales los republicanos
y los socialistas con un score de menos
de menos del 5 por ciento de votos y eso
es una debacle histórica en que se
diferencian bueno que tenemos cinco años
de un clic en a todo macrón en el que
hemos pasado una pandemia en el que
hemos pasado a la crisis del gil jones
en el que hemos pasado una guerra ahora
en europa pero yo creo que en lo que más
se diferencia 2017 2022 es el
crecimiento la presencia en la fuerza de
la extrema derecha en 2022
para que lo tengamos en la mente si
sumamos los votos de la extrema derecha
del bloque de extrema derecha en 2017
llegábamos entre el epen y dupont años a
un 26 por ciento del electorado hoy en
2022 si sumamos lepén symour y dupont
aignan llegamos al 32 por ciento del
electorado si lo comparamos con el 28
por ciento de macrón hoy podemos decir
que el bloque de extrema derecha es la
primera fuerza electoral en francia y
esto no es poca cosa y hay que hay que
analizar lo que está pasando en nuestra
sociedad para que tres de cada diez
electores comparten ideas de programas
de elección a derecha
williams no es solamente de extrema
derecha si se une lo que dicen algunos
analistas es que se une el voto
antisistema es decir de la extrema
derecha pero también de la extrema
izquierda llegamos casi a la mitad de
los electores que han elegido una opción
antisistema que es otro de los problemas
o sea porque es a ese voto antisistema
que es lo que le puede complicar a la
segunda vuelta macon
todos a lo macro evidentemente todos
algo el sistema impuesto entonces hay un
trasvase de votos que es lo que digas al
principio de un cierto electorado por
eso una parte no todo por supuesto del
electorado de milán son puede ser clave
bien porque vote ese trasvase el voto a
marín lepén bien porque se abstenga y
permita que marín le pen con menos votos
suba y ese es un votante y sistema que
es lo que muestra el hartazgo de una
sociedad que eso para mí es lo
preocupante de que sea real o no
quizá no es o sea es lo que hablamos
antes no es una visión no es la realidad
de francia pues la visión que muchos
tienen de francia recordemos que el
tercero en discordia estamos haciendo
referencia al izquierdista melanson
llegó el tercero en la primera vuelta
con un 22 por ciento y es ese 22 por
ciento el que intentamos analizar en
estos momentos qué cantidad de voto
pudiera macro en cuanto poder al epen o
cuánto puede quedarse en su casa y con
una abstención beneficiar quizá
indirectamente al epen por tener la
ultraderecha más movilizada
lo que lo que decía silvio es
exactamente como hay que plantear el
tema es el voto antisistema
hablabas antes de personas y personajes
en mi opinión sin lugar a dudas marín
lópez no ha cambiado nada por mucho que
nos presente sus gatos por televisión y
etcétera ella no ha cambiado es decir su
discurso sigue siendo un discurso
xenófobo que amenaza la situación de los
extranjeros e hijos de extranjeros y la
presencia europea en francia y francesa
en la unión europea etcétera pero eso no
significa que la gente vote a marín
lópez en en relación estrecha con sus
ideas que ella presenta en su programa y
dedic es muy difícil analizar la
situación hay un voto antisistema
generalizado lo cual no significa que
hay una adhesión ideológica clara para
los temas que xenófobos o racistas a
nivel de 30 por ciento en francia de ahí
la complejidad para analizar lo que está
ocurriendo
lo que está claro es que estamos en un
panorama tras la primera vuelta de un
país dividido en tres polos con un
presidente que ocupa todo el espectro
central y luego con un pueblo a cada
lado es decir es una francia tripolar se
habla mucho de la france et polar yo
creo que hay que analizarlo más a
detalle porque porque lo que la
selección nos muestra son una fotografía
del momento es decir sí es cierto
tenemos tres fuerzas que llegan a la
cabeza pero en política no es blanco ni
negro es decir después del 24 de abril
él no quiere decir que las personas que
hayan votado por el epen por macro o no
por mi lesión van a continuar apoyando
su programa es decir hay un voto útil
eso lo sabemos y eso lo vimos en las
cifras de la por ejemplo la derecha
moderada que se dividió entre entre
macro y el epen de las izquierdas que se
movió se micro hacia mi lesión y de la
extrema derecha que se vio entre si
moore y lepén yo creo que aquí
'la algo también muy interesante es que
un panorama que no contemplamos era que
cuando si moore lanzó su candidata un
escenario era que iba a restarle votos
al ver cuando realidad lepe no tuvo más
no sólo tuvo más votos que en 2017 sino
que sí hubo 2 millones de votos en una
candidatura de unos cuantos meses es
decir la extrema derecha fue la gran
ganadora del primer de la primera vuelta
hace cinco días hablaba antes silvia de
ese voto antisistema lo que nos vamos a
encontrar en dos en la segunda vuelta es
un referéndum al presidente al menos eso
es lo que la manera en que la quiere
plantear madryn lepén que ya está dando
intentando dar la vuelta a ese frente
republicano que siempre ha ido contra
sus intereses es decir el que siempre ha
impedido desde hace no olvidemos que
estamos estamos a punto de cumplir 20
años desde la primera vez que la extrema
derecha el padre de manning le pen en
ramadí llegó a la segunda vuelta y con
una gran abstención pero bueno la cosa
es que desde entonces el frente
republicano ha sido el cordón sanitario
contra la extrema derecha y ella lo que
quiere presentar qué es lo que ha hecho
ahora en uno de sus mítines del primer
mitin que ha dado en avignon de la
segunda vuelta ha sido yo hagamos un
frente anti macro que eso funcione
hombre ella sabe que tiene ese voto
antisistema que funciona y que luego el
mucho voto que esa es la clave que
digamos este voto cargamos de este voto
útil para la izquierda al final vamos a
volver todos los lamas la mayor parte la
mayor parte de los candidatos han dicho
claramente hay que votar a macro y no ha
dicho no ha dicho que hay que votar a
macro pero ha dicho ni un solo voto para
madryn le pen y
eso es lo que ya se le reprocho hace
cinco años han salido y lawson pero
digamos esa es la cuestión yo creo que
va a hacer la abstención y sobre todo si
funciona ese relato quedaría tengo mis
dudas porque estamos viendo como ahora
que manning le pen ya no tiene as the
move para para presentarla más más más
presidenciable digamos como se está
separando se está se están viendo
poquito las orejas al lobo y se están
separando las curvas que el primer el
día después de las elecciones parecía
que estaban rozándose ahora ya empieza a
ver una diferencia en las curvas entre
la intención de voto de amac con
jean-marie le pen
creo que el país está dividido también
por no sólo uno sino dos populismos hay
un populismo de la extrema derecha que
está constantemente hablando de la
decadencia del país debido a la
presencia de los extranjeros y a la
merma del poder soberano de francia en
el marco de la unión europea eso es una
forma de lo es uno de los dos populismos
y luego hay un populismo de izquierdas
que repite constantemente que este país
ha sido asolado por una política
neoliberal en los últimos 25 o 30 años
como si fuera el chile pues pinochetista
cosa que no se corresponde con
absolutamente nada de las políticas
llevadas a cabo no sólo por mack o si ni
siquiera por sarkozy es decir el estado
de bienestar social francés
prácticamente no ha sido afectado por
las políticas ni siquiera las de la
derecha pero sin embargo el discurso lo
que aparece en las redes sociales es que
estamos viviendo prácticamente bajo un
régimen de del ultraliberalismo
inspirado por los chicago boys y no se
corresponde en absoluto con la realidad
cotidiana de lo que pasa que es al mismo
tiempo hay que explicar lo que es el
proceso de la francia olvidada y del
malestar que hay en este país respecto
porque la extrema derecha ha llegado a
ocupar esos vacíos donde el estado quizá
ha dejado de funcionar en muchos lugares
de francia no en regiones
industrializadas por ejemplo del
cinturón del norte sí pero
son dos problemas diferentes las de
industrialización de los bastiones
comunistas del norte ahí sí que se ha
visto claramente un
traslado o una transferencia del voto
tradicional del partido comunista
francés hacia no el padre lópez pero si
la hija a partir de los años 2005
más o menos en cuanto a se ha ausentado
de sea un sentado porque no tenía
soluciones claras de digamos
sustitutivas de lo que era el gran
digamos el gran aparato industrial
minero y de siderurgia tradicional
había organizado esa región desde
mediados del siglo 19 eso sí que se ha
ido se ha ido a pique sin que existan
soluciones claras sino el traslado
digamos el que la gente acepte nuevos
tipos de empleos fuera de su ciudad de
residencia etcétera con todos los
problemas que eso conlleva pero bueno
españa conoce el tema de la espanya
vacía que también se podría podría ser
elemento de comparación con el tema que
acabas de plantear víctor luego cómo
está la cuestión de la franja olvidada
yo veo muy curioso que hayan a marie le
pen se le considera como alguien que va
a favorecer a las clases populares
cuando en realidad si nos fijamos a
detalle en su programa en su programa
fiscal por ejemplo en su programa
económico beneficia muchas medidas a las
clases altas entonces yo ya no entiendo
cómo es que si no entiendo por mata
lados y además un punto a favor de ella
fue el poder adquisitivo
ya agarre
esta estrategia que era la primera
preocupación de los franceses y en toda
su primera campaña fue en torno al poder
adquisitivo que pasó que para macrón era
una debilidad porque decía mi gobierno
ya ha hecho todo lo que tenía que hacer
entonces y proponían medidas ha
propuesto medidas menores pero esa
estrategia de marine le pen le dio
muchos muchos frutos a su campaña una
estrategia que vino por la coyuntura de
la guerra en nombre de hacer una pausa
en este momento y enseguida le dio la
palabra silvia en un minuto aquí en
primera plana hasta ahora
[Música]
france24 liberté égalité actually
france24 la economía día a día
liberté égalité actual y te seguimos en
primera plana esta semana analizando la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
francesas ese duelo reeditado de 2017
entre la ultraderechista lepén y el
presidente macrón que va a definir el
futuro político de francia y de europa
lo hacemos con víctor hugo ramírez
politólogo fredixon historiador y
docente en la escuela de altos estudios
de ciencias sociales y mi compañera
silvia yuso que me pedía la palabra
antes de la pausa estamos hablando de la
francia habilidad del discurso del epen
y nos contaba víctor cómo ha calado ese
discurso de
tono social si lo que quería apuntar a
la paradoja de estas elecciones que es
el candidato que más ha traído a la
juventud jean-luc mélenchon es el
candidato más mayor 70 años el candidato
más joven de estas elecciones que fue el
presidente más joven de francia macrón
que ahora tiene 44 años es el que atrae
al electorado más mayor que se ha visto
ese cambio impresionante en los mítines
que en 2017 había mucha gente joven
profesionales del tc era la media son 50
a 60 años que es lo que algunos dicen la
democracia senior a la que se va y luego
una candidata con mamá regla quien
creció por circunstancias todo lo que se
quiera pero creció en una de las en una
de las zonas de parís más acaudaladas se
presenta como la defensora del pueblo de
los pobres es decir que también pocos
son todas estas caras contradicciones
también paradojas que hacen que llegamos
un poco a la sección la que estamos ya
en freddie en la primera parte de la
campaña el presidente no hizo campaña
podemos decir ahora empieza yéndose
directamente lo hemos visto en cuanto a
empezar la segunda vuelta deudos obreros
fue feudos del epen y buscando ese voto
de ley son que por lo que pelean los dos
que dificultades o qué riesgos hay en
este movimiento de seducción del
presidente hay un riesgo porque la gente
puede no creérselo ese es el riesgo pero
por otra parte es imprescindible que que
de ese movimiento ya que la derecha
llamada civilizada ha desaparecido
prácticamente del panorama electoral
nacional en esta primera vuelta y no
cabe la menor duda de que es
imprescindible para mac con seguir
consolidando algo que ya obtuvo en el 17
y que se ha mantenido y es que el
centroizquierda
socialdemócrata le vota a maco
no vota menos ahora tiene que ampliar y
consolidar ese voto de izquierdas
moderada hacia él si quiere ganar la
segunda vuelta o sea que la clave de
cara a la segunda vuelta es saber hasta
qué punto es potente ese trasvase de
votos entre melanson y lepe que es lo
que muchos sondeos la demoscopia se
esfuerza estos días en estudiar parece
que hay un tercio entre entre un 30 por
ciento siempre está ahí en el punto en
el que sea así que habría un tres vasos
de ese voto antisistema entendemos con
abstención con la excepción en 2017 9%
del electorado que votó en primera
vuelta por mi elección asegurado aquí a
votar por lepén hoy en 2022 el 30 por
ciento de los electores de mediación
aseguran que votarán por ley pero ahí es
exactamente una función a mí lo que me
lo hemos visto esta semana en medios en
redes como explicar que un elector desde
la izquierda de mi elección pueda votar
por el extrema derecha de lepe y hay
varios factores hay hay mucha gente que
está muy enfadada por tener que votar
por matrona en la segunda vuelta y a mí
me llamaba la atención un reportaje que
cuestionaba a los giles jones y los
giles john decían es que no nada puede
estar peor voy a votar por lepén porque
nada puede estar peor que con lo que
estamos con otro y es es una rabia muy
comprensible pero hay que decirlo con
todas sus letras las cosas si pueden
estar peor si la extrema derecha gana
porque horas después de que la extrema
derecha gana quienes pagarán las
consecuencias van a ser las poblaciones
de origen magrebí las mujeres que portan
el velo etcétera etcétera es decir hay
este cómo explicarnos que las los
votantes de mi lección voten por macro
pero hay todo un
discurso de estos votantes una rabia que
existe que explica este traslado de de
los votos en cualquier caso si llega
macrón a repetir quinquenio ese malestar
va a estar ahí si la abstención es muy
grande puede perder legitimidad a la
hora de emprender una agenda de reformas
va a tener que que transformar su
presidencia en otra cosa silvia bueno
una de las claves será
creo que a lo mejor las legislativas
macro en 2017 obtuvo una mayoría
absoluta que considero como la
validación de su mandato si ahora no
consigue la mayoría absoluta
pues su mandato no quedará tan validado
y luego está el segundo factor que es
macrón macro mismo existe hasta 2027
como lo conocemos cinco años pero a
partir en 2027 no se puede volver a
presentar dos veces seguidas
es un movimiento hay varias figuras pero
figuras las figuras que salen son sobre
todo figuras de la derecha de philipp
bruno lm administra actual de economía
el ex primer ministro de adquirir
entonces este centro que también se basa
y que necesita muchísimo el votante de
centroizquierda trasvasado de
socialistas ecologistas etcétera
permitirá esto no se mantendrá no y
luego en la batalla interna se ha de
decir es un presidente que va a tener
que gobernar con con una estructura suya
que estará buscando liderazgos o sea que
puede crear conflictos internos más allá
de todos los conflictos externos crisis
políticas sociales etc el 15 imaginaba
unos charcos amarillos en 2017 quien se
imaginaba una pandemia no sabemos
todavía si la pandemia resurgió o no
vuelve otra cosa y luego bueno tenemos
la guerra de ucrania que ya han perdido
interés porque nuestra nuestra capacidad
de concentrarnos a veces es muy corta
pero sigue ahí y no sabemos cuánto va a
durar y cómo más va a afectar y no
sabemos si va a haber un par esto para
nos parecemos menos amenazados pero no
sabemos qué va a pasar en unas semanas o
meses o años entonces hay tantos
factores internos y encima externos
perdón y encima al interno de que va a
ser un gobierno que está buscando nuevos
liderazgos yo creo que eso puede ser
complicado ya en frederick como el
horizonte yo creo que para los hay que
explicar una cosa que no parece
no parece claro a primera vista la
constitución francesa por mucho que se
hable de monarquía republicana es una
constitución
parlamentaria
fundamentalmente parlamentaria eso
significa que efectivamente si gana más
con
las presidenciales pero no gana las
generales o las legislativas quien
detenga el poder será el primer ministro
y el presidente será decorativo y eso es
una de las características que siempre
se olvida es cuando hay lo que llamamos
cohabitación quien lleva el poder
efectivo del gobierno de la nación no es
el presidente de la república es el
primer ministro que se lleva todo sea
the wind o text o en ese caso entonces
existe una gran incógnita el día 24 de
abril no sabremos cómo se va a gobernar
francia a partir del mes de junio no lo
sabemos no me parece claro es que el eje
de coordenadas entre de izquierda a
derecha ha cambiado aquí lo que se
plantea es un duelo digamos entre
cómo llamar el multilateralismo
centrismo liberalismo de macrón y el
proteccionismo patriotismo
de la de la extrema derecha no es un
riesgo que en una democracia como
francia la alternancia de poder se
establezca en estos parámetros que la
alternativa a macrón sólo pueda venir de
un del antisistema
bueno estamos frente a una situación que
no se recuerda lo que ocurre en hungría
lo que lo que ha ocurrido en eeuu con él
mandando de trump que es exactamente esa
alternativa antiguamente tenemos una
alternativa de centroizquierda versus
centroderecha dentro de los parámetros
europeístas socialdemócratas o social
liberales etcétera y ahora estamos
frente a otro tipo de alternativa que
efectivamente parece ser mucho más
peligrosa que la que hemos conocido en
los últimos 30 años esta dicotomía ha
sido propulsado también e incentivada
por el propio presidente
es un escenario cada vez más complejo
se dibuja desdibujado un poco la
izquierda y la derecha pero hay temas
que también han movido de divisiones muy
añejas por ejemplo las divisiones de
clase que ahora vemos que nos dicen no
es que el presidente de los ricos y
vemos el voto que en realidad las clases
altas y las personas con diplomas son
las que votan macrón y las que las
personas sin diploma de menos de tres de
un salario de tres mil euros vota le
pueden decir se han reactivado algunas
divisiones del pasado eso es cierto pero
pase lo que pase el 24 de abril yo creo
que una cosa es cierta el 25 y es que el
25 de abril tendremos una francia
fracturada una francia dividida de dos
visiones de más de dos visiones
distintas que van a tener que lidiar y
que tener vamos a tener un quinqué nato
muy muy complicado
básicamente va a ser un escenario muy
complejo para el gobierno de macrón
tiene que fijarse en los resultados de
la primera vuelta porque porque no solo
es cierto ganó y reafirmo se legitimó su
programa pero sólo con un millón y medio
de votos más que li peng y con dos
millones más de votos que me lesioné
entonces cómo puede un gobierno el
futuro gobierno el gobierno que viene
del king que nato tener la legitimidad
para seguir con su programa hermético y
sin tomar en cuenta todo el otro
espectro político tanto de la extrema
derecha como de las izquierdas si lo
habrá aprendido macro en las lecciones
del primer quinquenio para intentar
vertebrar francia y llegar a esa francia
lidad ahora en el segundo no lo seas tan
digamos estamos en el escenario aunque
sea todo distinto como decíamos al
principio estamos en el escenario con el
que siempre ha jugado a maco y
él se les ha ido un poco de las manos se
han asustado en la vista las orejas al
lobo pero en el escenario en el que se
veía ganando es decir esta confrontación
está hoy o el
electoral para él y mala para el país
claro bueno bueno para el buena para my
independent mala pues sí para los
electores que se ven avocados y además
vamos a ver abocados una vez a hacer un
cordón sanitario
a pulsar un botón que debe ser un botón
nuclear que eso debería ser algo muy
excepcional y se ha convertido para mí
en una peligrosa herramienta más del
proceso democrático
frenar a un partidos a votar no por lo
que crees sino por para evitar otra cosa
es algo que hay en este actor por eso yo
creo que hay un enfado de los jóvenes
esté justificado o no que es han crecido
la gente veintipico años ha crecido sólo
teniendo que votar in extremis no por
convicción sino con para evitar algún
mal peor y eso también es un fallo
democrático yo creo que hay algo
intrínsecamente fallo mal funciona en
democracia si es una voluntad contra y
no por
bueno pero yo creo que es importante
también ser justos es decir si ese duelo
entre el centro razonable y la extrema
derecha un poco razonable se ha armado
así no sólo es por culpa de mccomb sino
también de la izquierda una izquierda
que hay que recordarlo - es una persona
que ha defendido a maduro ha defendido a
díaz canel ha defendido a putin a toda
la toda la retórica putin jana sobre el
peligro que y la amenaza de la otan
contra rusia que es
que uno puede considerar como
absolutamente mitológico eso lo ha
repercutido
lo ha repetido una y otra vez menos oa
lo largo de los años y eso hace que la
profundamente fractura de la izquierda
francesa y por otra parte del partido
socialista ha sufrido desde el año 83 la
incapacidad de decir lo que estaba
haciendo el partido socialista ha hecho
una política muy razonable de
centroizquierda o de socialdemócrata
siguiendo repitiendo digamos siguiendo
desarrollando una retórica de la
izquierda y peleona y es decir el
desfase entre lo que decía el partido
socialista y lo que hacía ha creado una
situación de verdadera desesperación
en la izquierda que la señora hidalgo se
quede con el 17 por ciento de los votos
no es ninguna sorpresa porque el partido
socialista no ha sido capaz o no no ha
sido capaz el mismo como presidente de
decir francamente y honestamente lo que
estaba haciendo por ejemplo al final del
mandato de holanda la famosa ley de
reforma del mercado laboral es una es
una reforma que anuncia exactamente lo
que iba a hacer macro después hay una
continuidad absoluta entre la segunda
parte del mandato de holón y maco y ahí
la izquierda tiene su responsabilidad
pues aquí lo dejamos el 24 veremos qué
decisión toma francia / macrón eleven
muchísimas gracias a los tres ya todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
primera plana
[Música]